[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que ça te fait de sortir
avec quelqu'un qui travaille sur les
autoroutes
bien sûr
je connais pas la personne quel est ton
prénom
alors j'ai une question qui me taraude
parce que tu sais que non non j'aime
l'amour j'aime la vie j'aime et je vois
qu'il a un très beau blouson jaune
fluorescent alors j'ai une question à te
poser ma chérie est-ce qu'il a un beau
stabilo dans le slip
maman
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu es heureuse avec lui tout
va bien
tu es amoureuse
vous avez des projets de mariage
d'enfants la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
je suis détendu là pour la chronique
c'est super
c'est super la famille
en fait ils sont là voilà j'arrive je
bosse avec vous bon ça va sinon parce
que
écoute je viens écouter d'ailleurs vous
êtes mon patron je viens montrer tout ce
qui se passe pendant les pubs pendant
les Magnéto et d'ailleurs c'est l'objet
du premier magnéto qui s'appelle La
Gazette des offres il va falloir calmer
Bernard Montiel parce qu'il fait que
mater des culs en ce moment
on commence avec Béatrice Rosen from
elle est qui a pris un petit coup dans
LEGO cette semaine
[Musique]
on connaissez Jimmy defoire découvrez
Cyril 10 fois
ils t'ont demandé
je peux demander si ils t'ont demandé je
peux demander si ils t'ont demandé
je me demandais si ils t'ont demandé
ça serait pareil pour tous
on cherche quelqu'un pour le remake du
cinquième élément Afida Turner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est partout Bernard et si vous
demandez qui est le plus humble sur ce
plateau c'est surtout pas l'animateur
et bien tiens en parlant de l'animateur
connaissez-vous son plus grand talent
quand il voit une fois un visage comme
un meuf il se rappelle tout seul
merci ça va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans un instant il va y avoir du très
lourd il y a du Afida Turner vous allez
voir les teter quand elle est venue
faire sa prestation ouh non non on l'a
dans la tête au bureau
une séquence que j'ai chopé pendant les
publières entre vous et Mathieu c'est
ils sont infernaux mais
très très lourd tu vas faire tout de
suite
alors il y a quelques jours donc elle
est venue faire sa prestation tout en
sobriété et
sa prestation faut dire que elle nous a
tous coaché et je vais vous demander
dans le prochain magnéto de bien
regarder les côtés de toutes les
personnes dans le magnéto oubliez la
FIDA concentrez-vous sur les têtes
retours vous allez avec des flèches
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thank you Touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de naissance du téton tu peux arrêter
ton fils non
[Applaudissements]
le week-end il a cinq six bébés autour
de 2020
donc j'aurai une déformation de la
glande mammaire l'enlever ma très bien
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends attends attends attends attends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore elle est incroyable et
Géraldine tu cherchais tu cherchais du
soutien
l'hypnotise c'est une créature un peu
ailleurs un peu spéciale mais elle est
elle intrigante donc effectivement je ne
sais pas si mais moi aussi j'aimerais
bien voir un duo Daniel Moreau à fila
plana
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre qui est votre
plus grand complice pendant les pubs qui
vous avez envie de parler comme ça je
pense que c'est Mathieu Mathieu en effet
Matthieu alors déjà c'est compliqué
Cyril Hanouna seul c'est compliqué mais
le 2 ensemble c'est une vraie année
[Musique]
j'étais malade toute la nuit je sais que
c'est moi dangereux de manger un truc
après que des oeuvres
notre cul c'est votre main non vraiment
bah ouais
on est obligé on mangerait dessus
un peu de son là
[Rires]
je danse avec un ami ah tu dois être
prêt à l'emploi j'ai vérifié tous ces
deux heures ça comme dans les chiottes
[Musique]
[Rires]
il est devenu beau gosse
sur les yeux ça met un chien qui avait
ça il avait les yeux vitreux
Daniel veut des enfants aussi je te jure
le gars qui la Ken elle a des enfants
elle envoie un centre aéré direct à 40
quarantaine d'enfants il y a une
quarantaine d'enfants qui sortent c'est
un
bus la salle de jeux depuis quelques
années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la ma chérie
parce que ça fait tellement longtemps
que ça va partir
mais là ça m'a débloquer des trucs tu
vas trouver une poêle Tefal les trucs
de fou c'est un BHV non mais c'est un
bazar de l'Hôtel de Ville Foir'Fouille
c'est la Foir'Fouille je souhaite la
Foir'Fouille
le retour d'une séquence que vous kiffez
ça s'appelle le on l'a vu alors pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est à la
voix cassé toi comment oui c'est fort de
faire ouh j'ai fait toute la journée
tu trouves sexy quand il fait ça
de Mathieu
[Applaudissements]
le principe du on l'a vu les
chroniqueurs estiment ne pas être assez
payé du coup ils essaient de trouver des
petits ménages dans des pubs dans des
films dans des chansons et d'ailleurs on
a enfin retrouvé le pourquoi du comment
sur les saintes Castaldi ça s'appelle le
on l'a vu
[Musique]
et si vous demandez c'est Nicolas perd
des Coffe était toujours vivant il s'est
relancé dans l'association
[Musique]
et regardez Gilles qui chantait une
chanson déjà prémonitoire il y a
quelques années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
esthétiques et c'était dans TPMP
dans une cérémonie royale sur un bateau
[Musique]
demain c'est le Black Friday et mettre
division ça y est il a déjà fait ses
petites en place
[Musique]
une presta incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on finit avec Baba bien sûr qu'il y a
toujours été très discret sur ses
amourettes sauf là où j'ai une image
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]